and now we were just talking with
brandon lewis among other things about
the campaign for the footballer
marcus rashford to get the government to
provide free school meals to the poorest
children
over half term and other school holidays
as well this week mps voted against
doing that but label wants that to be
another vote
we're joined now by the shadow mental
health minister dr rosanna
alain khan thank you very much for being
with us thank you for having me
so you're going to be pushing for
another vote on this what's the plan
absolutely the labour party are not
going to give up on our young people on
the children who are going to bed hungry
and the fact that 322 mps made the
morally reprehensible decision to vote
against free school meals this week is
deeply suddenly but i will say
that what has played out over the
ensuing days
is the very best of what it means to be
british our communities have stood up to
this government and say
and said we don't care what you have
done we
are angry and we are going to take
matters into our own hands and so we
have seen
you know local restaurants communities
councils
stepping up even though so many
themselves have been hit so hard by this
covert crisis
and providing support for children and
young people
and it makes me so proud to be british
and i know that marcus rashford and his
campaign
absolutely represents the best of our
country when do you think that vote
might happen then you know
well we are honestly hoping that the
conservative
government dig deep and look
introspectively
and perform a u-turn on this but we
certainly will be pushing for a vote
before christmas okay okay i'm keen to
talk to you about another story that's
emerged on the program today as well
we heard from bernard jenkin at the
beginning of the show calling
on dido harding the head of test and
trace to go
do you think it's time for new
leadership there look it's very
interesting i think
the huge take-home message here is that
the
the tories are infighting because even
they themselves can see
just how catastrophic the handling of
our test trace and isolate system
has been i mean should she go then do
you think it's time for her to go
well actually i think the real message
is about the people who are needing this
to work for them
we are seeing serco lining the pockets
of shareholders with 165 million pounds
of profit but not delivering the contact
racing we have been calling for as
labour party
for it to be in the hands of local
public health teams who have been
delivering a contact racing rate of 97.1
whereas circo if they're lucky get 68.1
it's time to put it back
to the local communities that know their
communities the new leadership then
her position is very difficult it's
untenable really but
fundamentally this comes down to the
responsibility of the government they
have
failed people and there are people who
are going into this christmas period
not knowing whether they're going to be
able to hug their elderly parent in a
care home
for the last time or not we need to be
speaking up for them
and for that we need to put it back into
the hands
of our local public health teams now i'm
keen to talk to you about
labour's own plan you want to see the
circuit breaker
a sort of short sharp lockdown to try
and drive down cases
so what i want to know about is the exit
strategy
would that be time limited or would you
be driven by the data
so we are calling for a short two to
three week circuit breaker because we
believe that ultimately
based on sage advice it would save lives
and be mostly
i know i understand why you're calling
for it what i'm trying to work out is
what is the exit strategy would you
would it last for a certain amount of
time no matter what happens
or would you be driven by the data no it
would last for a certain amount of time
no matter what happens and then we would
go back into the tiered system
okay i just want to have a look at what
kia stanley said at prime minister's
questions this week
he said this to the prime minister he
said is the prime minister seriously
saying
he would take a tier three area out of
tier three
with the r8 above one i don't think so
now are you seriously saying that you
would end
a circuit breaker lockdown if the r
remains above one because
i don't think you do that either we're
very clear that the circuit breaker
would be for a prescribed period of time
it would not be for a protracted period
of time
fundamentally this circuit breaker is
needed in order to get on top of the
shambolic test trace and isolate system
if we are able to get on top of that it
will protect our economy and although we
are not
and if the r8 remains above one you're
saying that you would just lift the
restrictions even though kia starman
doesn't believe boris johnson when he
says the same thing
we're very clear that the circuit
breaker would be
for a two to three week period only and
even the imf has said that if the
government don't take that advice and
don't act and do that now i mean look we
wanted it now over the half term period
when it would cause the least disruption
to people but it could cost our economy
110 billion pounds
the government have been asleep at the
wheel they have to act okay
i'm keen to ask about another story
around today we asked brandon uh lewis
about it too
about reviews reports that the
government is looking at bringing down
the south isolation period
from two weeks to potentially ten days
or even seven days
do you think that's a good idea i've
always been very clear from the start of
this pandemic especially with my work on
the front line how important it
is that we follow the science and we
follow the world health organization
advice on how long we should be self
isolating this is in order
to protect ourselves our families but
also more importantly everybody else
around us
and the british public have been
incredible they have shown such resolve
this has been going on for seven months
now
and the british public are tired and
they need hope but
it is only well it is essential that we
only do
what is safe and fundamentally it all
comes back down to getting on top of
test tracing isolate because if the
government were able to do that then
people would have some certainty
and there is nothing to say that if they
brought down the period to seven days
that people then wouldn't go out
off after three days so actually don't
think it'd have an impact on compliance
anyway
i think people are tired people are
tired and they need hope and they're
going into
a long dark winter we know that in the
first
phase of covid when when we had the
first peak
the ons figures showed that that
depression rates
um just just skyrocketed and
we have to understand that people have
been doing their best the majority of
the public have been doing their best
and i'm really proud of the public i'm
really proud of the british people
who are putting other people's safety
first as well as their own you're
talking about depression rates about the
long dark winter
it's so many of our viewers will be
feeling pretty down let's be frank
about the months to come um lockdown
self-isolation and social distancing all
taking its toll
how concerned are you by reports that
referrals to mental health services have
actually been dropping
i'm deeply concerned because i know that
that is not reflective of what we are
seeing at large and i would just like to
take this opportunity to say that the
nhs
are working incredibly hard they are
doing
their best and actually like mental ill
health
doesn't just doesn't discriminate it
doesn't know class it doesn't know
gender or
ethnicity and so many people have really
been struggling with their mental health
particularly our frontline nhs and care
workers which is why
labour called for a care for carers
package to put
their mental health first we know that
in june alone
32 of sickness days in the nhs was down
to mental ill health
i've raised this with the government
that that was more sickness days due to
mental ill health than to the
coronavirus itself but the government
just haven't been listening
the government need to have a plan in
place
a mental health and wellbeing strategy
going into this winter
that is what the labour party is calling
for they have to be gathering data
they need to be understanding where the
pressures are and they need to be
delivering for the people that need it
the most
isn't the problem though that for many
people the reason
they're suffering from mental ill health
is because they can't see people
they can't see their loved ones they
can't see their families
and does that not need to be taken into
account as well when we're thinking
about
imposing restrictions on people it needs
to be taken into account when we're
looking at the fact that test tracing
isolate has failed people because if
we'd got on top of that
it would have been so much easier i
understand why
your criticism is of test stress and
isolate but even if you look at someone
like germany for example whose test
tracing isolate system has been
praised their rate is about the same as
ours cases are going up it's
you can't blame the whole thing on test
tracking nicely do we not need to have a
wider conversation
about the impact that restrictions are
having on people's mental health
you're absolutely correct there are
people in some parts of the country
who've pretty much been in lockdown
since march
this government haven't managed to to
actually get on top of the virus
during that time which is why we're
calling for a short
two to three week circuit breaker to get
on top of the virus to drive the r
number down
and to give the government a chance to
fix test trace and isolate and we want
to
we want to work with the government to
make this happen it's in all of our
interests
but the british people are incredible
and they need hope and they need to know
that
they will get out the other side we will
get to next year and things will get
better but we just have to hold on to
that hope and know
that the government are doing all they
can to protect our mental health
and just finally you've recently been
fined
a thousand pounds just over a thousand
pounds for breaching
house of commons rules after you sent
out letters
saying that you were fighting brexit on
house of commons head of paper
prepaid envelopes during the election
campaign now
this is the third time you've breached
the rules in three years are you
becoming a bit of a serial offender here
no look the rules are important and they
are there to be followed the
the first time i broke the rules was
because on on paper that i paid for
myself
i used i used a picture of a crown port
collis i made a mistake i didn't i
didn't realize that that that wasn't
mistaken i then i then um
i declared my nhs payment for my shift a
little bit late
and i used i used paper
to respond to people who'd written to me
about brexit i did it in good faith i
held up my hands and said i'm sorry i
made a mistake
i'm human i'm not a career politician
but rules are there to be followed and
actually when i
realized that i'd made a mistake i
i straight away offered to repay the the
vm cost of the stationery and yeah i'm
sorry and i hold my hands up